love me some Canadians Canada's been
very good to me for a long long time I
can't complain for a very long time this
show is kind of the show that just keeps
going it is it's the little show that
could and now it's the show that just
won't die so you know it's it's unique
and and I think a lot of it is you know
it's I got to give I get it a lot a lot
of credit to the crew that that worked
this show day in and day out they are
the tireless unsung heroes of the show
I've said it before I'll say it again
the best crew on the planet and and some
of the best technicians film technicians
in the world live right there and good
old Vancouver Canada now your executive
producer actually credits the chemistry
between you and your on-screen brothers
devil we're actors so we can pretend you
know I yes there is something to say
about about both on-screen chemistry and
off-screen chemistry and you know Jared
now we're very very fortunate to to find
a companion with each other a friend a
brother someone that we really truly got
along with and and not just not just was
able to work together with but really
build both a relationship on an
off-screen and I think it shows in our
work I think it shows in the show I
think it shows on our set when you come
on our set one of the best compliments I
can ever receive is from a guest star
who says it's so much fun to work here
and I think a lot of that is something
that he and I strive for on a day-to-day
basis because he and I truly enjoy each
other's company which means we truly
enjoy working together which means we
truly enjoy being there on set and when
you're surrounding yourself with crew
like I talked about before that also
truly enjoys what they do and is really
really
proud of the product that we're creating
that creates an environment where we can
all have fun and be creative and your
wife joined for a couple of episodes
this season right she did it took me 13
years to wear her down I finally did it
and she came on she did a couple
episodes she was great she's amazing
I've always thought she was the better
the best actor in the family so it's
nice to see her kick off you know kick
off the dust a little bit and then get
back on the horse we were just outside
shooting b-roll of you guys with
scooby-doo and the and the fans going
crazy so first of all tell me about the
fans and the scooby-doo episode well the
fans I mean there's there's so much I
could I could bore you to death all day
about the the love I have for these fans
they're the reason that we're still here
you know you don't really have a show
unless you have an audience and and we
we have somehow managed to skirt the
odds for many many years even when
certain you know certain things maybe
didn't didn't go our way or we were on
the bubble to get cancelled or maybe we
just weren't you know the style of show
for certain executives whatever it might
be
our fans have stuck with us and they
continue to grow and they continue to
spread the word and that is why we're
here playing something scooby-doo tell
me about that episode scooby-doo it's
scooby-doo are you kidding me
I mean I grew up watching the show and
now I actually get to like be a little
bit of a part of it it's uh we we dove
in like headfirst when as soon as they
said Scooby Doo we were I mean all of us
we were just like in no questions asked
like tell me what to do